[Musique]
leur sang a été complètement drainer les
yeux de la victime masculine était
ouvert par des aiguilles la victime
féminine était dans ses bras toute
petite fille trouve tout prix une carte
postale a été envoyé un journal à paris
une autre à hambourg et une habitat
passif et le nom sont arrivés dans une
vive avec une carte postale
pourquoi il les a placés comme ça il
veut transmettre message
c'est là le baiser de rodin dante et
virgile un enfer
saturne dévorant un de ses fils ils ont
découvert un cinquième coupe
je crois que l'immeuble était précis et
bien préparer ce pépin vous avez
exactement quatre jours pour empêcher un
meurtre je vais devoir y répondre par
moi même je vous le déconseille
fortement
vous avez eu votre chance je suis
policier plus 30 ans le type de crime
que fait ce meurtrier est très
spécifique
il est extrêmement difficile à profiler
mais les monstres restait toujours des
monstres
peu importe ce qu'on fait pour les
calquer semble logique de manière
vraiment tendu
l'amour la souffrance n'a marre
non pas encore terminée
l'art est une blessure transformé en
gruyère